one thing that causes people's financial
problems to get exponentially worse
you've got a problem X and you're
getting ready to raise it X to the third
power you want to know how to make your
problem three times worse you already
got a problem you know now you make a
problem three times worse you don't deal
with it you just let it lay there think
about it you know you get behind on a
credit card it goes into default and
they don't call you and you know you
have an old credit card debt of two
thousand dollars laying there and you
don't deal with it eight years later you
look up you're trying to buy a house and
that two thousand dollars is now
fourteen thousand dollars cuz you can
deal with it the stuff doesn't go away
when you have a problem that is
associated with money a business that is
misbehaved like our last caller smother
a mess that you made where you just
didn't do something right I didn't do
something right and I made a mess I've
done that myself the the biggest way to
limit the damage of your stupidity to
limit the damage of the financial
problem is to be aggressive in knocking
it out passivity will cause you to get
deeper and deeper in the hole
exponentially not linearly I mean it's
going to blow up everything when you
don't deal with it it's a splinter under
the skin and it festers and you're going
to end up amputating your whole freaking
hand because this one tiny little piece
of wood under your finger you get
gangrene because you don't deal with it
you've got to deal with it and it's
unpleasant but it's more unpleasant if
you don't deal with it so whatever
you're facing however bad it is
I can promise you it's going to get
worse if you don't deal with it
so our phrase for the day
deal with it get all up in the business
get all up in the face get all up in the
grill of the problem and start punching
until the problem starts backing off
just keep punching just kick and bite
and claw and scratch at that problem and
kick it push it back do not quit just
lay into it hustling grind up some
ground because passivity will get your
butt killed it gets worse and worse you
ever notice that's true with
relationships - you got a relationship
problem you just let it lay it just gets
worse and worse Laurens done it but when
you sit down you go okay man we gotta
have coffee this is a problem we're
going today we're going to look each
other than I am we're going to talk
about this crap and you put it up there
on the table you know what it starts to
heal it starts to go away when you call
people out on stuff and you sit down
with them it starts to change
relationships now sometimes you're
dealing with evil people and that's not
true but by and large most people are
pretty good folk and if you sit down and
you work on that you can work through a
relationship thing with folks but not
dealing with it it just gets worse and
worse and worse you people that are
leading you got unresolved disagreements
inside your organization they just get
worse and worse and worse and worse and
worse and everybody starts gossiping and
they all start talking about each other
and it goes the whole organization the
culture goes down the toilet of the
organization because the leader is
passive and we'll let unresolved it's
agreements just fester in the
organization now not everything requires
you get a lawyer and sue somebody I'm
the last person to salute somebody I
can't stand that stuff but I tell you
what man if somebody's gonna come at us
we're not going to stand here and watch
it happen we're gonna come at them too
so get ready you know get ready you're
gonna come after us you better pack a
lunch because we're going we're gonna be
here all day and you know that because
we're gonna deal with it we want it off
the plate so we can go on and that
brings clarity to your life and it
leaves things alone so financial
problems financial situations
get worse with passivity passivity is
not an option
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind